네. 안녕하세요. 오늘 여기 어디
사업 대치동이 나와 있습니다. 그래서
여기 앞에 학원가가 있거든요.이 건물
있는 위치가 지금 학원가뿐만 아니라
여기 인근의 배우 세대도 되게
많아요. 여기가 다 지금
아파트입니다. 그 정도로 굉장히 많은
아파트들 사이에 있는 어 그런
건물이라고 보시면 될 거 같고 여기
어디 사업 촬영한 거 중에 규모가
제일 큽니다. 지상 9층에 지하 3층
그니까 총 12층짜리 건물이라고
보시면 될 거 같아요. 지금이 정도
되는 엄청 큰 규모의 사혹을 누가
소유하고 [음악]
어떻게 짓게 되는지 인터뷰도 하고
한번 사혹 구경도 하도록 하겠습니다.
여러분 가시죠.
>> 네. 여기 건물주분인 청정욱 대표님을
모셨습니다. 안녕하세요.
>> 예. 안녕하세요. 청정욱입니다.
>> 안녕하세요. 간단하게 자기 소개 좀
부탁드리겠습니다.
>> 시스터앤이라고 하는 화장품 브랜드
하고 있습니다. 추출 비중이 조금
높은 화장품 회사라고 봐 주시면 될
거 같습니다.
>> 여기를 매입하신 이유가 있으세요?
이쪽 위치를 제가 사실 여기를 매입할
때 되게 많이 고민을 했어. 저희가
화장품에서 사다 보니까 21년도에
강남을 매입할 것이냐 [웃음]
아니면 이제 성동구를 갈 것이냐 이제
고민을 되게 많이 했었는데 당시에는
김대표 님의 저소에 영향을 받고
거래는 그래도 강남이 잘됐다. 저희는
선능력과 한티역 사이여서 직원들이
출퇴근하기 좋은 위치라고 생각을 했고
지금은 또 약간 또 한 세월이 3,
4년 지나니까 선능력의 트래픽이 조금
줄었어요. 근데 이제 21년에 제가
선택할 때만 해도 선능력이 가장 좀
많이 사고 내리는 그런 역이어 가지고
그때 이제 선택을 했고요. 이게 지금
매입한게 21년도에
>> 21년에 계약을 했고 22년 초쯤
제가 등기를 했죠. 그때 이제 부지
매입비용이 315억 정도 됐고요.
영도하고 뭐 하고 이제 건물 올리고
진행을 했습니다.
>> 그래서 지금 약간 햇빛이 좀
많아가는데 안에서 좀 얘기 더
나누시죠.
>> 알겠습니다.
>> 그럼 21년도에 매입하고 명도하는데
어느 정도 걸렸죠?
>> 막상 명도하는 데는 뭐 한 3,
4개월 걸렸어요. 그래서 이제
명도하고 뭐 해체하고까지는 22년
중반 아, [음악]
>> 네. 이제 끝났는데 그리고 이제 원래
스무스하게 하려면 이제 22년 뭐
하반기쯤 해서 착공하고 쭉 했으면
이제 이게 23년 말이나 끝나는
프로젝트가 됐을 텐데 좀 욕심을 부려
가지고 설계를 한번 엎었어요. 그래서
이제 시간이 한 6, 7개월 뒤로 쭉
밀리면서
>> 올 연초 정도의 공공이 완료됐고요.
건설에 대한 프로세스를 잘 모르다
보니 [음악] 커머스하고 화장품하는
사람이다 보니까 서두르면 설계도 한두
달 만에 후딱후딱 뺄 수 있을 거라고
생각을 했거든요. 단순히 물리적인
시간뿐만이 아니라 심의하고 뭐 이렇게
하는 그런 시간들이 다 걸려서 실제로
사람이 방세서 일을 한다고 해도
절대적으로 확보해야 되는 시간들이
있으니까 계약서에 도장 찍고 나서
잔금 실을 때까지 시간 있잖아요. 그
시간 안에 설계를 하고 뭐 심의도
하려면 하고 해서 최대한 그가 기간을
줄이는게 잘하는 일이다. 모든
건축주는 욕심이 좀 생기거든요.
해보면 꿀팁 비싼고 유명한
건축가일수록 설계의 기간이 더 든다.
제가 두 번째 투입한 분이 업계에서
유명한 분이시거든요. 좀 저렴하고
젊은 설계사무소는 날래고 빨리 할 수
있을 수도 있다.
>> 사실 이거 말고 더 큰 프로젝트가
많아서 이게 어떻게 보면 또 이제
계속 후손위로 밀려나기도 하고 뭐
>> 프로젝트가 안 밀리더라도 원래 절대
시간을 그 정도는 잡아야 우리는 할
수 있다라는 뭐예술가
>> 그 그런 프로세스가 있더라고요. 예.
네. 공사비는 대략 한 어느 정도
>> 저희 공사비는
어 100억 조금 넘게 들었다고
보시면 될 거 같습니다.
>> 아 진짜 그 공사비도 어마어마하네요.
>> 그러니까 원래 처음 프로젝트에서는
60억에 처음 6억
>> 처음에 21년도의 계획을 잡을 때는
연면적 900평이면 뭐야 글린스터 한
600만 원 사는 실 있었잖아요.
60억이면 질을 수 있어 뭐 이랬는데
지금은 아마 뭐 연면적 6700평
하면 평상 천에 근접하게 다들 나올
거예요.
>> 그 이상돼요. 그러니까 불과
2020년만 해도 600, 700
이런 얘기 했거든요. 처음에 저
프로젝트 계열를 짤 때 아 60억
드는데 좀 오르면 뭐 예비 뭐 5억
정도 65억 내외면 지은다 100억어
[웃음]
>> 이게 진짜 다 시간이 돈이어 가지고
>> 맞습니다.
>> 대략 시세에는 어느 정도 될까요? 뭐
550억 정도 되는 거 같습니다. 그
안에는 건물 가액은 뭐 100억 정도
반영이 됐고요. 땅값이 이제 좀
여기가 200평 정도 되는데 대략 뭐
한 2억 정도 평가되는 거 같습니다.
[음악] 이제 보니까
>> 그러니까 여기 팔리는게 보통 2억
정도 팔려 가지고
>> 저는 오히려 닦아 잘 모르니까 역시
잘하실 거니까
>> 네네서 최근에도
>> 팔리고 그래서
>> 아 그리고 지금이 건물은 몇 [음악]
층 쓰세요? 저희는 이제 6층, 7층
두층 정도 사용하고요. 사실 저희가
이제 원래 뭐 7, 8, 9층 쓰
했었는데 반지아 유정수라는 채널이
있거든요.
>> 자기가 반지하에 살고 있는 이유가
여기만 임대가 안 나가서 그렇다고
하는데 저희도 마찬가지로 8층, 9층
다 임대 잘 나갔어. 그럼 이제
남은게 이제 뭐 3 4 56인데 아
인천님 먼저 들어오시고요. 건물주
하면 좋다 그랬어. 되게 비슷한
대표님도 많이 봤어요. 원래 이제
꼭대기 [음악] 층에 되게 화려하게
쓰려고 하다가
>> 사실이 공간이 친구 뭐 4m 뽑아
놓고 여기다가 인터뷰 하고이 들으면
삐데기 되게 좋겠다 였는데 뭘 삐데기
뭘 삐대 우리는 가서 일해야지
이러면서 [웃음]
일단 간단하게 질문 좀 여기까지 하고
좀 내려가 볼까요?
>> 원래 우리가 쓰려고 이따위로 친고를
높여 놓은 건데
>> 몇 미터예요 이거? 3.5가 좀 넘을
거예요. 저 위까지는 한 3.8쯤
되고 밑이 3.5쯤 되고 인차인
쓰시겠다고 하면 저희는 안
쓰겠습니다. 여러분 가는 [웃음] 거
학원 좀 들어오거든요. 역건물 건물
좀 더 신축하셔 가지고 대충요 두
건물은 꽤 예쁘게 보이지 않을까 싶긴
합니다.네
>> 여기는 저희 사무실 오피스고요. 지금
공사 중이어 가지고
>> 아
>> 2주 뒤에 이제 2주에 이제 가시
>> 저도 사실 처음 봅니다.
저희 집기가 6층에 와 있긴 하고요.
전녁 면적 한 50평 정도 되고요.
임대 면적이 뭐 70경이 약간 안
되는 그 정도 구조로 돼 있습니다.
>> 임대학이 딱 좋은 면적 사용하기에도
>> 더 큰 거를 원하시는 데들이 있는데
잘 몰랐어요. 정용가는 훨씬 커야
되는구나. 나중에 지나고 나니까 알게
되는데
>> 어떤 임차인을 고려하겠다를 맞춰서
설계하는게 좋은 거 같아요.
>> 어, 맞아요. 맞아요.
>> 요렇게 테라스들을 조금씩 해 놨어요.
그냥 저는이 건물에서 4층 테라스를
제일 좋아하긴 합니다. 이거는 저는
흡변을 안 하다 보니까 금면이었으면
좋겠으나 후흡 후흡 잡은 입장에서는
눈비를 막으면서 [웃음] 마우컷
담배를 필 수 있는 공간이야. 사실
또 요즘 후흡자분들 입장에서 생각해
보면 어디 오갈 데가 없어.
이 사람 입장에서 진짜 매력적인
공간인 거 같습니다.
>> 4층, 3층, 2층은 또 확 달라요.
테라스랑 숨겨진 공간들이 좀
있습니다.
>> 위에 층보다 여기가 난은 거 같아요.
>> 요런 개방감이 있고 그러니까 너무
좁으면 테라스 같지 않은데 돌아갈
수도 있어 가지고 요렇게 해서 이렇게
되어 있고요.
>> 층마다 다 좀 달라서
>> 층마다 다른 건 호으로는
갈리더라고요. 임자를 맞출 때 5층을
기대하고 왔는데 아 5층은 방금
계약이 됐습니다. 그 4층도
똑같으니까 4층 하시죠. 이게 되는데
4층을 고려하신 분이 4층
나갔는데라고 하면 아 남들이 똑같이
짓는 건 하실 이유가 있었어.
[웃음]
여기가 이제 2층.
>> 네. 중공을 하고 나서 사실 내부
계단을 하나 만들었거든요. 그래서
이제 다음 주에 아마 계단이 다
들어올 거예요. 1, 2층을 투선
플레이스가 들어오기로 되어 있는데
이게 공사 자체는 3일에서 길게 보면
일주일 걸려요. 저는 금방 할 줄
알았어요. 근데 요즘 이제 내부
공사에서 이렇게 슬라브를 하는 걸
대수 공사로 치부하더라고요. 실제로
3개월 걸리는 거예요.
>> 아.
>> 아. 건물 부시는 것도 사실
일주일이면 부시는데 허가 받고 막
그러는데 시간이
>> 이것도 똑같네. 계단 설치도 대수성
공사고 기간은 실제로 서두른다고 해도
두 달 반 이상을 잡는게 맞다.
그래서 좀 다 돌아봤는데 지금 아마
이걸 보고 계신 분 중에 이렇게
사업을 지으려는 분들이 계실 것
같아요. 그분들한테 한마디 조언을 해
주신다면
>> 물론 이제 저도 사업을 지을 때 무슨
생각이었냐면 저희 회사가 성장하고
있으니까 우리가 지금은 뭐 저희가 두
층, 세층 쓰지만 원래 지을 때 4년
전에는 어차피 우리가 다 쓸 거니까
우리 맘대로 설계해도 돼라는
생각이었어요. 그러다 보니까 좀
이렇게 설계를 좀 한 면이 있는데
B를 생각하시고 [웃음] 만약에
우리가 사업이 잘돼서 다 쓰게 된다면
쉬운 옵션이니까 바꾸는게 합리적인
확률인 거 같다.
>> 아, 네. 그리고 마지막으로 대표님
유튜브 하시잖아요. 유튜브.
>> 아, 네. 네. 제가 이서블이라는
채널을 다시 유튜브를 11월에 시작할
거고요. 많이 돌아와 주세요. 오늘
영상은 여기까지 하고요. 어, 다음
시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다.
>> 감사합니다. 고맙습니다.